what was your first success as a
screenwriter well my first you know
obvious success was love lies writing my
second script I wrote was a drama I
wrote it in 96 the fall of 96 and you
know six years later it's lund dance at
one the Sundance the Waldo salt award
and it was bought by Sony classics and
released by Sony and yeah that was
definitely first sort of obvious success
I mean I'd had other things like option
and things but that was like sort of the
conspicuous success and you know my
brother my little brother I showed it to
him
Labor Day weekend 1996 and we were both
back in my mom's house and we're both
happened to be there and I said oh man I
gotta read this I just read I just
written the first draft I said I think
this is kind of good and I don't know I
think this is kind of cool he read and
he was like I want to do this and and he
had not shot Boogie Nights yet he was
about ready to shoot Boogie Nights dot
fall and so that fall he shot Boogie
Nights with Paul Thomas Anderson Paul
Thomas Anderson read love Liza and
actually gave it to Michelle satyr at
Sundance and they considered it for the
lab the Sundance lab so that was very
exciting I ended up moving out to LA in
February of 97 and then we started the
process of trying to get the movie made
and then eventually it was shot in 2001
Kathy Bates was in it but
yeah so that all that stuff felt
successful you know I mean the idea that
you know Sundance was interested and I
and you know it's great because I mean
you know I just had a short film that I
wrote and directed at Sundance in 2015
and Michelle sadder is still there and
she came up to me and you know we're we
still know each other from when I she
called me on the phone and I was in
upstate New York in the fall of 96 and
she interviewed me about love Liza and
Paul had referred the project to them
and said hey you should check this out
and she you know I'll respond to the
script it didn't get in to the lab but
they were always tracking it and then
obviously it was accepted and Paul's
movie hard eight was developed it was
originally called Sydney and his first
feature was developed through the
Sundance lab - so that was her bro that
was the relationship with the lab that
Paul had so yeah so all that stuff was
exciting I think but the most popular
sort of thing that people would say
would be the oh you know Sundance one
the wort or whatever and but there was
many other things that populated my
professional career that were like oh
this is exciting and you know when you
sat down to write love Liza was that in
your mind that it was going to have a
trajectory like that and did you expect
well yeah okay so I sat down to write
love Liza and I you know I've been
driving a cab for three and a half years
in Chicago and I just quit like about a
month before cuz I'd sideswiped a
limousine and I was like sort of having
this like mental breakdown or whatever
and I was like I was like I just want to
write and my family gave me a little bit
of rent money so that summer I just
didn't work and I was like I gotta do
something and so I remember August 5th
it's very clear I will I woke up and I
written like two pages of it and I wrote
in like eighteen days I just sat there
and wrote the whole thing and
and I always wrote it with the sense
that I would play the guy or not really
like I would play the guy but I wrote I
did write it with a sense that what if I
was gonna play the guy and that really
helped me as a writer you know it was
like it really got me I don't know I
don't really even really done that much
a lot since then but I should probably
think about that sometimes because it
was really effective I was like what if
I play this guy you know and it was like
it was that Orson Welles II type of
thing where it was like it was like I'm
gonna do everything like sort of when I
was a kid and I did this so I wrote it
like that you know I didn't write it for
my brother I didn't and I showed up to
my brother's just cuz I was like I was
like this is good man you know and I
knew it was good you know and I gave it
to him and he was like I gave him like
10:30 at night you know or something and
he read it and the next day he was like
I just read the whole thing you know and
he totally responded to it he was like I
want to do it and and you know I think
it's like historically looked back and
people are like it looks like like I
guess it was like two brothers making
this movie together but my brother ended
up being Philip Seymour Hoffman and
doing all these other things so I look
historically it looks like one thing but
he actually was just an actor who was
like I want to do this role you know cuz
it was a cool role it was a hard
but it was it was you know he liked it
and then we went on this journey
together and you know and it was so yeah
so that's I'm not sure what the question
was but yeah you know so that was what
it was yeah that just wow did you expect
this type of journey and it sounds like
that wasn't no it was like it just it
was like no you know you didn't you
don't expect all sorts of things you
know and then you just it did I didn't
expect it would take so long you know to
make it even though I was like there are
so many things you're like oh my gosh
you know and you didn't expect it not to
do sorts of things and then you expect
you know but I'm very we're very lucky
because we made a film that a lot of
people there's plenty of people that
it's their favorite film you know and
it's like that's the
I think that's the thing that a writer I
tell people it's like the greatest
success is if you can write somebody's
favorite film you know like if you if
you if they have like a poster of your
film and you might write something that
like but if they're like I you write
something that's their favorite film you
know that's it doesn't get any better
than that you know because you're never
gonna get everybody to like your film
and the money's gonna always disappear
so so if as long as you have somebody
come up to you and I still have people
coming up to me and are moved by the
film tear up when they talk about it
they go oh my god you roll up Liza you
know and it means something to them and
you're like that's so it's fortunate
because that is the kind of thing that
has guided me because it's like nothing
else matters like except like giving
your audience that experience and if you
can get that to get that to people and
have some people think it's a crap or
whatever and so people think it's a
nepotism job or you know whatever and
it's just like flimsy or whatever it
doesn't matter because it's like it's a
very it's a personal experience films
are personal there's plenty people that
I love Citizen Kane I think it is genius
and other people just hate it you know
and it's like there you go you know so
were you thinking about the characters
while you were driving before the the
limo accident were you you know how
because you saw I came up with the idea
for love Liza because I was I was when I
was driving a cab I came up with ideas
all the time you know and and I just it
was one of those ideas I just saw a
woman coming she was homeless
something would she was by the gas pumps
at a gas station ice you know it's your
taxi driver you're living at the gas
station a lot and you or you you're
always there and I saw her and I was
like and I just put in my mind at this
idea of like a yuppie which is not an
acronym that's used anymore but it's
like a professional white guy in a suit
suddenly starting to Huff gas I just saw
this guy's like huffing
and that was the germ of the idea and
then I had to come up with a motive and
then I came up with the motive and then
I started writing it from there and then
I created everything from there and I
came up with like a sort of a MacGuffin
II hook so to speak it around you know
ten minutes into the movie and it's that
that hook sort of drove the movie and
and then I just like I said I just sort
of splatted it out and III honestly you
know I probably could have been
rewritten and a bunch more times you
know it just wasn't but it did get
rewritten and I did fix a little bit and
as a baby writer then you know so that's
where it came from
you